hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one term that
you're going to encounter quite
frequently as you read through epictetus
is discourses and look at his
interpretation of stoic philosophy it is
often translated as appearances or
external impressions there's other ways
in which it's translated but it's all
one Greek term namely Fantasia this is
the plural for fantasy hi-yah it also
means imagination it's the word that we
get fantasy from but it comes from the
Greek word for appearing phenomena that
which appears to a person that which
puts itself in front of them you might
say that much impression works because
it's what impresses itself upon them and
in the stoic way of looking at this and
the way of using this term it covers an
incredibly wide range so epictetus will
actually go so far as to say that reason
itself with the rational faculty is a
complex system of appearances meaning
that it's something that we can actually
experience something that we can grasp
something that we can encounter and
stoic philosophy is oriented in large
part around figure out how do we deal
these appearances one thing that I do
want to stress as well is that it's not
just a human matter animals like lady
says use appearances so animals react to
their environment their and even plants
to a certain extent could be said to
react to appearances in a very broad way
insofar as they react to their
environment animals do as well so when a
dog you know sees another dog and it
thinks hand when I go over there and
find out what's what with that other dog
is it is using in the sense that epic
you know systemic but it's using
appearances it's reacting to them it's
engaging with them and in some way
human beings are more complex as
rational beings because we not only use
appearances and we can use them rightly
or use them wrongly we can also
understand appearances we're able to
take a step back and to reflect upon
them to say what's appearing to me isn't
necessarily the way things are even
though the appearance is trying to tell
me that that's the way things are or
just start comparing them against each
other or to even you know use a sort of
systematic mode of inquiry with respect
to them so human beings have you might
say a greater capacity but they also
have a greater stake in appearances and
there's more ways in which one can go
wrong as human being with appearances
then the other animals do the other
animals are largely driven by instinct
there's some things that they will get
wrong but you know that's not really
that big of an issue for them whereas
for us human beings there's lots and
lots of ways that appearances can
mislead us so epictetus is going to say
we need to be ready to deal with
appearances he says this in in Chapter
II of book 3 he says this in many other
places as well we need to be ready to
deal with appearances and it gives us
some guidelines and some advice about
them so what a bit of advice is we
should think to ourselves
does this really concern my moral
purpose or my Faculty of choice that
which is within my power the prior ASIS
what is it at the core of who I am or is
it about something else is it is it
something that I don't really have
control over something that is in an
indifference something that reacts it
matters how I use it
but it ultimately has no intrinsic value
in and of itself so that's one thing to
keep in mind so you know II says as we
exercise ourselves to meet sophistical
interrogations
you know when people try to put one over
on us sophistical interrogations
maybe translate that is you know the
best example in our own time advertising
you know if you don't want to be misled
by advertising or mislead by people
making fallacious political arguments or
you know things along those lines you
need to you need to exercise your mind
you need to become a critical thinker
similarly we need to do the same thing
he says with respect to appearances so
he says we needed we need to exercise
ourselves daily to make the impressions
that come upon us because these to put
interrogation
to us they say hey why don't you do this
or wooden things be better if you did
this or did you better move away to this
over here so he says here's some
examples so one so son is dead how do we
answer that that lies outside of the
sphere of the moral purpose it is not an
evil there may sound a little cruel and
cold hoods at one but it's it's applying
the stoic philosophy very consistently
his father has inherited so and so what
do you think of it that lines outside
fear of the moral purpose it is not an
evil Cesar has condemned this person
that lies outside of the sphere the
moral purpose is not immediately seen
going over and over the same sort of
ground doesn't really concern the core
of the person the moral purpose or the
Faculty of choice what we have control
over or doesn't it many of the things
that our appearances really don't
concern us they are there you know to a
large extent externally we do know the
appearances happening
within ourselves we you know when we
engage in a judgement about ourselves
that's that's a kind of appearance but
for the most part they're not things
that are within that realm now in
another place chapter 27 of book 1 he
talks about appearances asserting things
to be or not to be in a certain way and
he distinguishes between things
appearing to be in a certain way and
whether they are in a certain way so he
tells us you know for example
appearances come to us in four ways
either things are and seem to be or they
are not and do not seem to be or they
are and do not seem to be there's a
discrepancy there between appearance and
actuality or they do not seem to be and
yet they are so he says in all these
cases the business of the educated man
is to hit the mark whatever be the thing
that de-stresses us against that we want
to bring up as he calls it
reinforcements so we need to be ready to
deal with the sorts of you know
suggestions you might say about how to
interpret matters that are constantly
coming to us from the world from the
things that we deal with from culture
also you know in some part coming from
our own projections onto that reality we
are in large part responsible for how
things do appear to us you know what
weight we give them how we how we react
to them
so we need to have some sort of
reinforcements ready to deal with
appearances what would be some examples
of that
some of them has to do with you know how
we develop our habits but here's here's
some other examples he talks about
having arguments ready at hand or
reasonings when death appears to be an
evil we must have ready at hand the
argument that it is our duty to avoid
evils and that death is an inevitable
thing for what can I do
where should I go to escape it you know
if we have that line of thinking that we
have not just you know written down
somewhere and we can you know bring it
to to to bear upon the situation then we
can see that although death does happen
and it's certainly not something to be
preferred it's not an evil at least
according to the stoic doctrine so if
that's the case then we don't have to be
disturbed by that appearance we don't
have to say oh this is so terrible you
know you know how do I avoid cannibal at
all that I have to be unhappy he gives
all sorts of other examples as well I
watch a lot of those lines but many of
them have to do with having ready to
hand what we could call arguments or
what we could call lines of reasoning
about things you know he doesn't use
this example but you could think about
if you have anger problems then maybe
you have ready at hand the notion that
comes from anger management which is as
soon as you become angry you become
stupid and you're not reasoning well and
you probably should take a break right
if you have that sort of thing ready at
hand then you can oppose it to the other
appearance if you don't have to right at
hand if you're just trying to you know
recall what you read a couple weeks ago
and skim through or heard about in you
know a training session
you were you know not taking notes in
but rather thinking about what's from
lunch you're probably not gonna be that
well equipped to deal with with those
appearances another thing that he points
out this is in section 18 of book two is
that our hair our reactions to
appearances eventually become habits
that become consolidated into habits and
so we want to be careful about how we
feed our habits how we modify them I
have a whole other court concert video
about epictetus inhabit so you can you
can consult that but you know let's look
at one example that he brings up it says
today when I saw a handsome lad or
handsome woman I did not say to myself
would that a man might sleep with her
and her husband is a handyman for the
man who uses the expression Hampi of the
husband means happy is the adulterer
also what's going on there he's
analyzing his own processes his typical
processes of thinking about things
of reacting to the appearance of the
beautiful body and he's saying that's
not really the way I don't want to think
about things anymore so when I meet up
with that sort of thing as I'm going to
do you know you're always running into
some people that are attractive right so
how do you how are you going to prepare
yourself for it he says I'm not going to
follow that line of reasoning any more
because there's there's something wrong
with it
he goes on and he says I do have a
picture to myself the next scene what
would you know sort of follow along with
that the woman herself in my presence
disrobing and lying down by my side he's
not undressing her with his eyes he's
not imagining what would it be like to
be with that person he's developed some
sort of control over the things that are
suggesting themselves to him so he's not
just carried along by the appearances
where the appearances would typically
want to take us or were our own flawed
moral you know choice processes and
reasoning processes would would take us
because of the habits that we've
established which become a kind of
second nature so you know that's a case
where he does have some things ready now
there is another piece of advice that he
gives us particularly helpful when it
comes to appearances as well this is
also in the chapter 18 of book 2 he says
that when we run into appearances what
we want to do is delay reacting to them
and then test them put them to the test
so how does this work he says if you
confront appearances with thoughts the
kind of thoughts that you can you will
overcome it and not be carried away with
it but to begin with be not swept off
your feet by the vividness of the
impression but say wait for me a little
Oh impression allow me to see who you
are and what you are an impression of
allow me to put you to the test and
after that do not suffer to suffer to
lead you on by picturing to you what
will fall
otherwise it will take possession of you
and go off with you wherever it will but
do you rather introduce and set over
against it some fair and Noble
impression and throw out this filthy one
and if you form the habit of taking such
exercises you will see what mighty
shoulders intellectual shoulders you
develop what sinews with vigor so the
idea there is is we want to cultivate a
habit of delaying of saying wait a
second I'm not going to react to this
even though I want to even though that
seems to be my natural tendency
I'm not going to react to this in a sort
of automatic fashion instead I'm going
to think about things
to reflect I'm going to mull it over and
then I'll see if it has the same you
know via Nancy if I if I give it five
minutes or if I say I'm going to sleep
on that this was very good advice so
he's giving us quite a few tools or he's
providing us with a kind of arsenal by
which we can tackle the constant barrage
of impressions or appearances that we're
going to run into he has people living a
life